okay I want your help with something
this actually does not have anything to
do with the YouTube issues that we're
experiencing every once in a while I
just like to reflect on the format of
the show and think about what changes we
might be able to make to improve the
show based on changing demands changing
interests from the audience and of the
different platforms that were on sort of
shifting and re-evaluating and very
often we'll consider a change and then
we'll end up not doing anything because
the consensus ends up being keep doing
things the way that you're doing what
you're doing is working at least to some
degree don't fix something that's not
broken but we've in the past also
sometimes made good changes to the show
which from my perspective have improved
it and the show has continued to grow so
in a sense they weren't bad decisions at
least not obviously so so remember that
for every idea I'm about to suggest to
you the constraint we have is that we're
doing a daily TV and radio show that's
an hour long so we're working within
that time frame of an hour in order for
the show to fit in to the format of the
nearly 200 TV and radio affiliates that
we have that's the show that gets
chopped up into pieces for YouTube and
they're turned into our daily audio
podcast so don't freak out all of these
are just ideas they're based on things
I've heard from the audience most
frequently but none of these are changes
were necessarily making these are just
ideas that I will open the door to hear
from you about number one a lot of
interview related ideas some people
don't like the interviews on the show
they just want to hear commentary
there's no rule that says we have to
keep doing interviews we've done
something like 1500 interviews on the
show booking interviews is time
intensive we could eliminate interviews
altogether and we could add stories so
instead of doing six stories per show we
could get rid of interviews and do eight
stories per show we could cut the
interviews but not add any stories
meaning we'll still do six stories but
we can devote a little more time to each
of those six stories we could cut
interviews and cut the number of stories
to only four which would mean the show
would become instead of sort of like a
summary of what happened in the last 24
hours or over the weekend we would
choose four stories and cover each story
for about fifth
in minutes but we would only be covering
four things per day that would that
would change the nature of the show we
could extend the interviews make them
longer but cut them to only a couple of
times a week so instead of four thirteen
to fifteen minute interviews per week we
would do just a couple but they could be
a half hour long instead of just
thirteen to fifteen minutes we could do
one interview per week and it would be
the entire show so imagine that maybe
Wednesday the show instead of being news
and analysis is just an hour interview
with someone who warrants an hour of
discussion and then the rest of the week
would be just news stories those are
some ideas live calls now I know that
the live calls are controversial we did
a poll about live calls previously and
overwhelmingly the audience did want to
keep live calls even though lots of
people hate them and want them to go so
live calls are not on the chopping block
right now but we could change when and
how we do live calls so right now we do
live calls on the Friday show and then
at the end of Monday through Thursdays
shows I'll play a voicemail from the
audience and react to it we could
instead look at for example getting rid
of the voicemail segment getting rid of
a half-hour of live calls on Friday and
just to do two or three live calls at
the end of each show so we get rid of
voicemails we do like 10 minutes of live
calls at the end of each show but
there's no big block of 30 minutes of
calls on Friday that's a possibility
there are more logistics for that
because we'd need to open the phone
lines every day unless we recorded all
the calls at once which would make some
of them maybe stale and outdated it is
more work on our end but it's an idea
and as many of you know I'm all about
ideas I'm all about big ideas small
ideas medium ideas stale ones new ones
whatever I'm throwing them out to you so
here is how I want to hear from you
about this only by email there's a
reason why it's too easy to just put up
a poll on Twitter or on our website or
on YouTube and let people vote and just
click something without really thinking
about it and the thing is that most
people often don't want anything changed
but if they're given a list of options
they'll just pick something and we get
sort of cloudy data if you actually care
enough to want something changed on the
show whether it
from the options I mentioned or
something different altogether email me
through the contact form at david
pakman.com ok david pakman.com click on
contact fill out that form and tell me
which of these ideas you like if any
tell me if you want everything to stay
as it is tell me if there's a change
that you would like that i have not
mentioned ok all of these ideas and
others I'm willing to consider and the
advantage of having to email me instead
of just clicking a poll is that if you
number one have an idea I didn't mention
we can also include it and consider it I
want those as well but if you want
nothing changed that's also useful to
hear because if 80% of the audience
writes in and says David don't change
anything that's important for us to hear
the whole point here is the show is for
you I want the show to be what people
want in terms of the format obviously
I'm going to still pick the guests I'm
going to still cover the stories I want
to cover but as far as the format goes
let me know what you think I'll give it
like a week or so and then I will come
to you with the results and whatever
decisions we make about the format of
the show